it's amazing to think that for a lot of
people drastically improving health and
performance could be as simple as just
switching to the right shoe see most of
us wear shoes with a large heel
a thick sole a thick squishy sole
and a narrow toe box like one of these
it's a good shoe by the way just
not as good as it could be
and these shoes are in contrast to what
we call minimal shoes or barefoot shoes
these are shoes with a wide toe box
absolutely no heel very minimal soul
essentially mimic going barefoot and
obviously actually going barefoot also
has the same benefits it's why i've been
wearing barefoot shoes now for over two
years and i've seen incredible results
across the board and it's why i
recommend it to everybody else as well
so a key thing to understand is the way
that a barefoot shoe will impact on your
biomechanics so with a shoe like this an
old-fashioned traditional shoe you have
this large heel and what this does is it
encourages you to strike the ground with
your heel like so by having this large
heel and by hitting the ground with your
heel first you're therefore sticking
your leg out in front of you fully
extended at the knee therefore you can't
bend the knee to absorb any of the
impact and that jolt has nowhere to go
but up through your leg in a barefoot
shoe like this one
you don't land with your with your heel
because there's not much padding on the
heel it hurts therefore you're going to
land the way that you naturally would
land if you're running in barefoot you
know the way we evolved to do so instead
you're going to land on the forefoot
like so directly underneath your center
of gravity and with your knee bent and
your hip and your knee are therefore
able to absorb that impact like a spring
this is what we were designed to do it's
good for building tendon strength and at
the same time it's far less likely to
lead to injury and deterioration over
time
one of the first and most important
things we need to consider when thinking
about barefoot shoes and barefoot
running in general is the way that it
affects your toes because in a barefoot
shoe or a minimal shoe you have a much
wider toe box what this means is the
toes can splay as they're supposed to so
imagine that your foot lands in a small
hole or a small ditch what would
normally happen if you're in bare feet
is that your toes would splay out they'd
fill that hole and this would give you
the purchase and the grip necessary to
then push yourself off and continue
running anyways however if you have a
very narrow toe box and you're
essentially balanced on this wedge of
foam then your foot will either fit in
there entirely he'll fit in there
partially in tip or it won't fit in
there at all either way you've got a
much less secure grip on the ground
you're far more likely to tilt and tip
your ankle which can really hurt this
can actually change the shape and
structure of your foot over time if you
look at someone who wears barefoot shoes
you'll notice that they have wider
splayed toes that look like they've
stretched out because they've got room
to breathe however if you look at anyone
else who wears regular shoes with a
narrow toe box the toes are much more
bunched together they might look cramped
and bent over and obviously this isn't
how they're supposed to look
and as if that weren't enough this can
even impact your performance negatively
because it prevents you from pushing off
of your toes as you're supposed to when
you run for starters when you're in big
heeled shoes your feet are basically
pointing downwards such that you're
already in a state of plantar flexion
your feet are pushing off the ground
even when you're just standing still
this gives you less space to push off
further and essentially renders the toes
pretty much useless when it comes to
running and performance this is a big
problem because we know that training
the muscles that control the big toe and
the four little toes the hallucis longus
and the flexor digitorum longus can
actually improve physical performance
can improve running speed and jumping
height this isn't just speculation
studies have shown that wearing barefoot
shoes whilst training can actually
improve your performance whether in
barefoot shoes or not increasing running
times reducing fatigue and reducing your
ground contact time as you spring off
the ground much more quickly
so let's take a break from those chilled
vibes to relax with a nice cup of coffee
this one being from jarvie who of course
are the sponsors of today's video this
stuff comes in a bottle with a liquid
that you can just drop into your coffee
you can add one or two teaspoons and
then just mix it in with some milk with
some hot water maybe add a little bit of
honey if that's your jam and you'll end
up with a really tasty coffee at the end
of it and it genuinely is a lot nicer
than just an instant coffee and it's a
lot more convenient to make at the same
time you don't end up with those little
grains floating in it also happens to be
dairy-free sugar-free plant-powered
non-gmo and ethically sourced my
favorite i've tried so far is this 100
arabica artisan roasted if you guys love
coffee then i definitely recommend
giving it a go give it a try and if you
go to
forward slash www.buy.jarvycoffee.com
which is linked in the description down
below by the way then you can get 25 off
your order if you use my code which is
also bioneer
and now back to wandering around a large
manor house
as you do by the way guys i'm here
filming today at the beautiful middle
aston house where they very kindly
allowed me to come and film and even fly
my drone which is rare the grounds are
absolutely beautiful and my parents
stayed here the other weekend and they
said that it was a wonderful experience
so if you're in the oxfordshire area and
you're looking for a place to stay then
i highly recommend checking it out
another key thing to consider here is
how regular shoes actually cut off your
senses you lose a whole bunch of
proprioception so if you had bare feet
and you were running you'd be able to
feel the texture and the shape of the
ground underneath how slippy it was even
the temperature all this information
then allows you to make tiny adjustments
in your stance in the amount of force
you're producing in which muscles are
contracting and how much which would
allow you to essentially push off of the
ground in the optimal way if you take
away this proprioception by essentially
standing on the same phone block
wherever you are then you're not able to
do this and therefore you're essentially
running with some of your senses missing
it's like running blindfolded this is
something i noticed in a big way the
first time that i wore barefoot shoes
which were the five finger shoes put on
the shoes i went balancing along a beam
and i could feel the shape of the beam
underneath my feet over time these
effects compound and you might find that
you actually lose that sense in your
feet don't use it and you lose it so
that might mean that even then when
you're walking around barefoot around
the house you might have less
sensitivity you might be less aware of
what's underneath your foot and this
won't cut it as training anyways because
your floor around your house is pretty
much flat and carpeted or wood so
there's not really much useful
information coming in now imagine that
you're a little bit older you've reached
advanced years congratulations you're
walking down the stairs how much more
likely do you think it is that you're
going to fall down the stairs if you've
lost that sensitivity in your feet this
might even be bad for the brain because
you're essentially processing less
information every single minute of the
day less information is coming in your
brain's working less hard therefore it's
going to deteriorate faster barefoot
running or running in minimal shoes
makes trail running far more viable
because you're now able to feel the
ground beneath you without twisting your
ankle this in turn can increase
proprioception in the ankles check out
my video on ankle strengthening and this
can therefore improve our ability to
produce energy and reduce our ground
contact time this is another reason that
those people who trained with bare feet
actually saw faster running and greater
overall improvement another big drawback
of traditional footwear is what it does
for your mobility because essentially by
having your heel slightly lifted off the
ground you're constantly shortening your
calves i mean your calf's in a shortened
position for the entire day so is it any
wonder that you struggle to get into a
deep squat without falling backwards due
to tight ankles or that you experience
knee pain
attempting things like a squat in
barefoot shoes immediately makes those
movements more authentic so you're not
putting yourself at that advantage angle
i do believe there's a time and a place
for things like squat shoes or squat
blocks that elevate your heels slightly
allowing for an easier range of motion
so you can pump out more repetitions
without putting any strain on your
joints before you've got that mobility
or just when you're taking it a bit
easier however i do think you should be
able to get into a deep squat as i said
in the previous video i think it's a
fundamental human movement if you can't
get into it you're essentially not able
to use your body as it was intended this
is going to translate to things like
lower jump height and a greater chance
of pain and injury and who knows what it
does for the anterior tibialis this is
in a constantly stretched position and i
can only imagine that it's similar to
the effect that sitting has on the
glutes where they're constantly
stretched weak and inactive again is it
any wonder that we're constantly hurting
our knees
now in terms of which shoes you could
get like i say these are vivo barefoot
shoes and i'm a big fan of these they're
a little bit more on the pricey side but
they last for ages they're comfortable
and at the same time they don't look too
weird i've got this pair here
which is my more my very well-loved ones
for you know sports
trail running etc and
these things have
been really good to me they've lasted
for
over two years i think now like i say
there's loads of other brands feiyu is a
really popular one very minimal shoe
much more affordable another great
barefoot company that i just discovered
is based and they make some really
comfortable barefoot shoes and just do a
quick google you'll find there's loads
of options out there now what i will say
is if you're going to start wearing
barefoot shoes don't just throw on a
pair of best foot shoes and go for a
sprint around the block on concrete
because this is a quick fire way to
really injure your knee it's what i did
and yeah i had a bad knee for quite a
long time after that you've got to ease
into this it's not something you're used
to unless you have been doing it and so
you've got to do it gently that means
slow runs i mean he's not wearing it 24
7 right away at the same time it means
initially starting on softer ground this
is the other thing you need to consider
is that when we were barefoot we had
softer floor naturally so we're not
necessarily equipped to deal with those
hard surfaces but as long as you're not
sprinting on concrete right away you can
build up to this gently when you're
landing on your forefoot you're actually
going to be protecting yourself like i
say so it's perfectly viable just don't
launch in there right away take it
slowly ease into it and like i say
always listen to your body
what i'd really like to ram home is just
what a finely tuned instrument the human
body is and how our attempts to improve
on it are almost always misguided at
best in his book born to walk author
james earls describes how our bodies
evolved to allow maximum efficiency when
walking to allow us to walk with nearly
zero conscious thought and whilst using
very little energy this is possible
thanks to the constant tension held
throughout our body by the facial system
this is called tensegrity essentially
your body's not just a stack of joints
on top of each other like a tower of
blocks we maintain tension in order to
stay upright and that's why you collapse
if you relax faster and connective
tissue contain lots and lots of
mechanoreceptors that can sense changes
in force and length etc and these allow
us to respond to tiny changes in our
position and our gait and not even have
to think about it via inbuilt reflexes
so for example when you lift your foot
off the ground you have a natural reflex
to dorsiflex to lift your foot upwards
this of course is to prevent you from
scuffing your toe and catching on
anything and then when your heel touches
the ground that change in length is
sensed by the fascia and you begin to
plantar flex in other words you push
your toes downwards so that you can
stand flat on the floor this all happens
without us even thinking about it
likewise the plantar reflex means that
when you stimulate the bottom of the
foot you naturally grip with your toes
if you push on a baby's foot on the
bottom they'll naturally grip with their
toes this of course is to provide that
extra grip so we can push off the ground
even that looseness of the skeleton is
in service of this so that when you land
whether you're running or whether you're
jumping your bones will actually move
slightly within your body and not only
does this send more signals throughout
the body it even preloads the tendons
creates a tiny stretch on them so that
you can then return that energy more
powerfully without having to contract
the muscles at all this is a very energy
efficient way to walk there are
thousands of examples of reflexes like
this that have evolved over thousands
and thousands of years and these allow
us to walk whilst thinking about other
things whilst maintaining energy which
is one of the ways that we got ahead as
a human species and it starts with the
feet because your feet are what hit the
floor first and that's why they and your
ankles are so rich with muscle spindles
and mechanoreceptors but sure you go
ahead and wear your nice comfy shoes
[Music]
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys know in the
comments down below what you think of
barefoot shoes and whether this is
something that you wear or you're going
to start wearing after watching this
video if you like this training that
looks at more than just your aesthetics
or your performance and a few lifts then
you might enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
the protein performance system that's an
80 plus page ebook and a over two hour
long video tutorial that shows you all
the moves and how to do them and it'll
address every aspect of your performance
in one single program i'll put a link to
that description down below and either
way thank you so much for watching this
one guys and i'll see you next time
bye for now
[Music]